Among all kinds of pain that a human goes
through, Child birth is generally
considered to be the most severe.
Yes!
The pain that a female goes through is
unbearable.
So we have all given our mother that intense
pain while coming
into this world.
But have you ever wondered about how you got
this life?
What were the series
of steps that made you grow into this structure
from being a single cell?
Let’s have a look at this most important
process that helped us gain life.
Yes!
I am referring to the process of FERTILIZATION!
How do we define it in simplest words?
Fertilization is the process in which a male
gamete fuses with a female gamete
giving rise to a zygote.
So how will this process begin?
When one sperm among all the others is able
to penetrate the egg cell then the egg releases
certain chemicals.
These
chemicals make sure that no other sperm will
now penetrate this egg.
The first step begins now when the male nucleus
from the sperm fuses with
the female nucleus that is already sitting
right there in the big fat egg cell.
The fusion stimulates a cascade of reactions
which will further give rise to
several successive cell divisions.
The consecutive cell divisions then give rise
to
an EMBRYO that will further develop into an
ORGANISM.
So is this process of fertilization the same
in all the organisms?
Think for a
moment!
In order to answer this question, we have
to keep in mind two major
facts.
Firstly, the process of fertilization is simply
the fusion of gametes.
Secondly, the place where the fusion of gametes
can take place may be
different in various organisms.
So now can we answer the question correctly?
Yes!
The simplest answer is that the PROCESS of
fertilization will almost be the
same.
This is because it involves the FUSION OF
GAMETES.
However the LOCATION where fertilization occurs
may be different in animals.
For example in humans the baby grows inside
the mother’s body.
However,
have you seen babies of frogs?
They are not born from inside the body of
female frogs like in our case.
This gets us to the concept of types of fertilization.
The first example explains that fertilization
occurs INSIDE the FEMALE’S BODY.
Hence such a type is referred to as INTERNAL
FERTILIZATION.
In this case the
sperms from a male’s body enter the female’s
reproductive tract and reach the
fallopian tubes where the egg cell awaits.
The fusion of both completes the
fertilization process inside her body.
All higher animals like mammals exhibit
this type of fertilization.
Now can you guess the next type?
Yes!
It will be EXTERNAL FERTILIZATION.
As
the name says, the process will involve fusion
of gametes OUTSIDE the
FEMALE’S BODY.
Frogs are examples belonging to this category.
In this case,
the unfertilized eggs are released in the
water.
Now the sperms from the male
body will be released on these eggs and will
fertilize them.
As a result the
fertilization process will be accomplished
in the water outside the female’s
body!
Many aquatic animals including fishes exhibit
this type of fertilization.
This is how fertilization takes place in animals.
Now the most important thing
we need to know is how the embryo develops!
Do watch our next video to know this important
process.